so we start with breaking news and just
in the last half hour a barrage of
rockets has begun to be fired from Gaza
towards Southern Israel dozens are being
intercepted by Israel's Iron Dome
defense system the Rockets were fired
just a short while after Israeli
airstrikes on Gaza the Israeli military
says they were targeting launch sites by
Palestinian Islamic Jihad at least 16
people have been killed in the Gaza
Strip in the last two days let's go
straight now to yumna elside she's in
Gaza City voice she's just taking cover
from the rockets that are being fired as
we speak Yuma tell us what's happening
what can we see
yes Folly Rockets are now being launched
from the Gaza Strip from different areas
um we can you can see them coming out
from different areas from all directions
at the same time from the gaza's trip
being launched towards Israeli towns
right now
[Music]
we are surrounded by barrages of rockets
that are being fired from everywhere uh
the sky above us is full of smoke
as we watched tons of rockets being
fired from the Gaza Strip in this
instance
look I mean these brockets are being
fired from the Gaza Strip towards
Southern Israel but they appear to be
above the Skies of Gaza can you explain
that
again I'm sorry Folly again
just explained to us why we're seeing
the Rockets being fired over the Skies
of Gaza when they are being fired from
Gaza towards Israel
yes I mean they are fired from Gaza
towards Israel but as they pass because
they're coming from different areas
um they could be actually launched from
the north from the south from the east
from the West we can see them uh drawing
Maps over us over our heads in the skies
of Gaza as they're being launched from
here and towards moving towards the
Israeli towns or being fired towards the
Israeli towns and that's why I'm saying
we can see the smoke covering the Skies
of Gaza as these Rockets are being fired
now
and it must be absolutely terrifying for
the people down below where you are
where other people are further down on
the street perhaps Sheltering in houses
what are people doing at this point
well already there was a very high uh
sense of fear and tension among the
residents of Gaza everyone was staying
at home people have limited their
movements since uh yesterday and all
night these hours in the morning people
only went out to get a very limited
Necessities uh uh in in in case they
needed anything from nearby supermarkets
other than that the entire Gaza Strip is
closed in Old shops all major shops all
facilities have shut down so everyone
was already waiting for this moment uh
but now with with the amount of rockets
that have been launched in in just a
matter of minutes together that huge
number of rockets being fired at that
time this also causes a great amount of
fear among the people
um I mean we're journalists we're on the
rooftop here um filming and and and
Reporting and there was and there is
fear Among Us so uh you can imagine how
it is for uh the residents of Gaza who
are also uh hearing uh strikes have been
hearing strikes Israeli air strikes in
the early hours of the morning and now
the launching of the rockets and also uh
the the explosions of the Iron Dome
Rockets trying to intercept these rocket
launch I mean it really is extraordinary
scenes that you're showing us you know
all of these Rockets being fired over
Gaza City it is not a large area but
still this was a lot of rockets we're
used to hearing of rockets being fired
from Gaza towards Southern Israel but
how unusual is it to see them in this
quantity
yes I mean from where I am we're we're
almost in the middle of the Godzilla
city and we can see uh the Rockets being
fired from uh uh in the northern port in
front of us as I was explaining we're
standing on the rooftop of our uh
building so we could see them from the
north we could see other Rockets being
fired from the East and uh and others uh
uh on the other on the other direction
from the West so it's it's really uh
it's really uh um very
it's very actually a
it's very terrifying to see such uh a
scene at the same time all these amounts
of rockets being fired uh with this
intensity and this huge number all at
the same time we have witnessed a lot of
launching of rockets before barrages
being launched but usually from the same
location or same direction but to find
them from several directions at the same
time this is something that has caused a
sense of of an anxiety and fear here
Among Us journalists reporting and
filming this everyone was trying to look
at all directions to find Rockets being
launched at the same time
I fully appreciate the the job that
you're doing there is is not easy
especially as you were literally coming
under Fire of rockets overhead this was
a real message wasn't it being sent by
Palestinian factions to Israel
yes fully so we don't know if this is
just an initial response to the
assassination of the three Islamic Jihad
commanders or this is actually just a
response on the Israeli airstrikes that
have been taking place this morning on
uh military sites belonging to al-q's
brigades now uh as I just explained the
intensity of the rockets that were
launched the amount of the rockets that
were launched uh this is something new
this is something new for uh the people
here it's something new for Gaza to be
launching that amount more Rockets now
we can hear more Rockets now being
launched so you can see that the time
the time between every barrage and the
other is is very is
yes it's very limited it's very uh small
so
um this is something that this is
something that hasn't really happened
this is a new experience that we're
experiencing from the Gaza Strip in
terms of Rocket launching
you know if you feel safe enough just to
stay for for one more question as we as
we watch these Rockets continue to be
fired from the Gaza Strip towards
Southern Israel as human are saying a
massive barrage of rockets there now can
we hear the air Sirens going off is that
in Gaza
foreign
you're going to have to repeat that
again the sound of uh the Israeli drones
above our heads is very high and it's
really interrupting the connection I can
barely hear you just wanted to find out
if the noise that we just heard there
was Air Raid Sirens
the sound is cutting I can't hear you
okay it appears we do have a few
connection issues understandably with
young uh I'll say there in Gaza City she
was speaking to us as a barrage of
rockets was being fired from the Gaza
Strip towards Southern Israel those
Rockets coming from all parts of the
strip towards Israel even over her head
as she was talking to us let's go over
the border now and we can speak to Villa
Marx he's in Ashkelon in Israel villain
those were really extraordinary scenes
that we saw in Gaza Rockets coming from
all parts of the city there are very
tightly knit Urban Enclave headed
towards Southern Israel what were you
seeing from that side of the Border
well Laura you can see behind me there's
quite an open series of fields giving us
quite a view of those various barrages
over the last 45 minutes or so they're
continuing now and what we saw was as
you pointed out multiple different
trajectories coming from different
origin points mostly heading over our
heads towards the coastline and we've
seen the Iron Dome from a couple of
different battery locations intercepting
them maybe a dozen Rockets about 45
minutes ago another dozen a few minutes
after that and then maybe 10 minutes ago
as you were speaking to Yuma there are
many many more probably 30 or so
different explosion sounds as those
intercepted Rockets fell to Earth after
the Iron Dome did its uh did its
interception what's so interesting here
though as well I don't know if you can
see in the far distance on the horizon
here there are some plumes of smoke
rising up we've heard from the Israeli
military that they have used airstrikes
on a couple of different targets it's
looking to try and stop some of those
rocket Crews as they go about their work
according to the Israeli military and
we've also heard sirens both in our
location slightly further south from
here instead of in parts of Ashkelon
which is just a few kilometers up the
road as far north as Ash Dodd which is
even further up the coast and of course
we're hearing that one single rocket at
least has landed inside sterox and
there's more you can see now more
interceptions by the Iron Dome there
those small plumes of smoke in the
distance probably about five or six
kilometers from our position as those
Rockets leave Gars and territory and
enter into this part of Southern Israel
Laura well I'm just explained to our
viewers what the Iron Dome system is and
how effective it is I mean we saw so
many Rockets coming from Gaza and you
say only one or a very few number
actually get through
yeah so projectiles that leave a
territory that's under essentially
surveillance it's a it's a wide series
of uh radar systems the Iron Dome that
looks for projectiles that are airborne
it then sends up its own projectiles to
intercept them and over the course of
let's say 45 minutes we've seen maybe 60
different explosions we can hear those
explosions as well a few seconds later
because of the distance what that means
is those interceptions have taken place
so far we have one report of a rocket
Landing to Earth which means the vast
majority of these have been intercepted
by these systems put in place by the
Israeli military okay and just explain
what residents are doing because even
though this Iron Dome does exist
obviously some Rockets do get through
and there must be a lot of fear
throughout people living in these border
areas
yeah there's a lot of people passing us
on the roads here there is still traffic
people traveling relatively quickly as
you might imagine there are military
checkpoints along a lot of the major
roads here trying to discourage people
from traveling through this region
particularly at the moment people that
live here have been told over the last
24 hours or so to stay close to shelters
during the the siren sounding of course
people encouraged to enter into the
shelters and we've heard yesterday from
the local government that dozens of
families from some of the communities
here which have now subsequently been
targeted today have been encouraged to
move away at least temporarily we had
heard earlier this morning that prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu would be
reviewing this situation seemingly and
I'm going to make an assumption here
based on the activity today they will
not be relieving some of those measures
being placed on residents here we heard
from him last night that he would like
people living in this part of Southern
Israel to take instruction from local
authorities when it comes to their
security okay Willem thanks very much
villain Martin the in Ashkelon in Israel
let's go back now to yumna El Saeed we
can now see her she's up for us in Gaza
City
you know just give us an update on on
what's been happening in the last few
minutes while we've been talking to
Willem
yes
sir being launched from Gaza we're
hearing also uh the sound of rockets
fired from the Iron Dome uh system to
intercept those Rockets we can see a lot
of spoke in the sky around us
um
after the recent garages that were
actually uh fired from different
directions in Gaza it's it's it's quiet
now for these moments
but we can still see the smoke from the
other uh if you can hear now
these are rockets by the Iron Dome
system trying to intercept Rockets so
probably since the rockets by the iron
job are being fired we know that other
Rockets are being fired from uh
different areas that are a little bit
far from the Gaza City so we can't see
them but we can hear the explosion of
the Iron Dome Rockets trying to
intercept them
is bringing us all the very latest there
from Gaza City we're a barrage of
rockets has been sent from all parts of
the Gaza Strip towards Southern Israel
just in the past 15 minutes or so Gilman
is going to keep an eye on events that
for us many thanks indeed